the u.s presidents called for dialogue
with the kremlin after signing off on
new
sanctions against russia the broad
sanctions are to punish russia for
interfering
in last year's u.s election and
orchestrating cyber attacks and other
hostile acts
moscow denies the accusations and says
it will respond
in kind now is the time to de-escalate
the way forward is through thoughtful
dialogue and diplomatic process
the u.s is prepared to continue
constructively
to move through that process my bottom
line is this
where there's an interest in the united
states to work with russia
we should and we will russia seeks to
violate the interest of the united
states we will respond
let's get more now from bernard smith he
joins me live from moscow uh bernard has
there been any reaction yet
from politicians in moscow
we're expecting later today uh to hear
from the kremlin's
spokesman in his daily press briefing
and sergey lavrov russia's foreign
minister
is having a press conference with his
serbian counterpart later
on friday where we were where we may
well hear more russia hasn't said
explicitly what is going to do yet in
response
to the u.s sanctions but almost
certainly
we know that the u.s is going to expel
10 russian diplomats well almost
certainly
russia will at the very minimum
reciprocate with
that there is a long list of courts of
american
complaints against russia from
allegations of interference
in presidential elections cyber hacking
the jailing of opposition politician as
alexei navalny the occupation of
crimea and a host of other what the
americans call
malign acts of russia denies any power
taking any part in all of this and the
first response we had
was from the foreign ministry uh
spokeswoman maria zacharova
and she says that biden's sanctions
contradict his desired
his intent his stated desire in a phone
call on tuesday night with vladimir
putin to normalize ties she says this
aggressive behavior
will receive a decisive rebuff now
economically russia's
ruble recovered some of the losses it
had suffered ahead
of the announcement of sanctions and
that's because it's believed
that the restrictions placed on dealing
in
russian debt are not as severe as they
might have been
but there's more the americans could yet
do
okay baron smith there bring us up to
date from moscow thank you bernards